good morning it's tuesday today's video
is like the last season of game of
thrones it comes to you in seven parts
and will be filmed partially in
absolute darkness part one so listen i
have to go to the hand doctor because my
finger isn't working for reasons
hopefully unrelated to the fact that
i've signed my name over 500 000 times
in the last 10 years and need to sign it
a further 100 000 in the next three
months so
let's go on an adventure part two the
2021 project for awesome is coming soon
it will go from noon
on february 12th to noon on february
14th
quick backstory the project for awesome
is a 48-hour livestream extravaganza
fundraiser and celebration of efforts to
decrease
earth's overall worldwide level of suck
i'm being lit entirely by my phone by
the way we got a lot of darkness here in
indiana in january
in fact you know what let's wait for the
sunrise filling out some paperwork
containing information that the doctor's
office should already know
right so during the first half of the
project for awesome we raise
unrestricted funds for pre-selected
charities this year partners in health
and save the children two organizations
our community has worked with for over
10 years
and then during the second half of the
project for awesome we raise money for
charities chosen by you in fact if you
make a project for awesome video about
your favorite charity
tens of thousands of dollars could go to
that charity but more on that in a
moment
part three an explanation so we moved
the timing of this year's project for
awesome because one the holiday season
is pretty crowded and two as you may be
aware 2020 was a bit of a mess
related a few perks from the last
project for awesome still haven't gone
out which i'm
really really sorry about the p4a is an
all-volunteer operation and so shipping
often takes a while but kovid profoundly
affected our ability to manufacture and
ship perks and i'm sorry
and we think we have it figured out and
it's going to be better this year
part four we need matching donors now we
know that many of you have donated very
generously to our project in sierra
leone and that many more of you are not
in a position to donate and we get that
there are many other ways to be involved
in the project for awesome see part five
but if you can afford to donate 500
or more to this year's project for
awesome please join our matching fund
there is a simple and easy google form
in the doobly-doo and also you can just
email us
matching donors help everyone else's
donations go further and are a big part
of the reason why over the last 10 years
the project for awesome has been able to
donate over 10
million dollars to charity so thank you
great news i don't have arthritis i have
a sprained ligament so i'm fine to power
through all right let's go home
part five you should make a project for
awesome video where you introduce us to
an organization
you care about and make the case that
they are doing good and important work
that our community should support people
can then watch and vote for your video
at projectforawesome.com which will help
inform
which charities get the money raised
during the second half of the project
for awesome so even if you can't donate
you can potentially raise lots of money
for organizations you
care about but this year project for
awesome videos must be uploaded to
youtube and submitted at
projectforawesome.com at least 48 hours
before the p4a actually starts so that
our community can have more time to
watch and share videos more info in the
doobly-doo part six perks as always
there will be lots of great perks
available if you donate like no spoilers
but sarah has been making these
amazing collages from old magazines
oh and also because we're working with
the donation platform tiltify we can
finally accept
paypal donations it only took 14 years
part 7 the closing hank i am so looking
forward to this year's project for
awesome it's always such an
encouragement something i really need
right now and also it reminds me what
our little video blog project is
ultimately
about as it says on my 2021 vision board
more awesome
less suck hank i'll see you on friday